One possible explanation is simply that the
router is misconfigured. In other words, no one
actually intended for the router to advertise a
false route, but because of a misconfiguration the
router does so. The AS seven zero zero
seven attack that we discussed last time Was
actually the result of a configuration error. Second,
a router might be compromised by an attacker.
Once a router is compromised, the attacker can
reconfigure the router to, for example, advertise false
routes. Finally, unscrupulous ISPs might also decide to
advertise routes that they should not be advertising.
To launch the attack An attacker might reconfigure
the router, which is typically the most common
way an attacker might launch an attack. The
attacker might also tamper with software, or an attacker
could actively modify a routing message. In addition to tampering
with the configuration, the attacker might tamper with the management
software that changes the configuration. And the most common attack
is a route highjack attack or an attack on origin authentication.